and uh as tony told me she's really uh
she wishes she had silvio's accent but
she's italian too um
in in origin at least uh
tony is a professor in columbia
university after many years in
university of toronto and uh tony's
research area is proof complexity
complexity theory but he's done work in
many many different things
in fairness and on other works and i'm
at awe
and she's also been a visitor to simon
city several times especially she was
attending um
my first year and she was there and we
became close friends and i'm very
grateful for her friendship also
and tony is really incredibly versatile
it's been recognized uh in in many ways
and i'm looking very much toward
her talk which is about replicability
pseudo-determinism and proofs so please
tony
thank you can you hear me
i'm all mic'd up okay um it's really a
privilege to be here um i'm going to
just start by
saying that i'm talking about
replicability and pseudo-determinism
proofs because i feel like
i when i associate this big
you know these these different research
areas when i think about them i think
about simon's institute and being and
being in berkeley and this is this would
not have been replicable without
my many collaborators and the main ones
uh
related to this work as shafi and
russell max hopkins rex lee jessica
sorrell who are students of um
russell's and probably other people's at
ucsd and rahul synthetic and unlike
silvio i probably won't i didn't time
things so it's a good chance that i will
like usual not get to my last slide so i
decided that i would actually start with
my last slide um
so you can leave after this one if you
want um does everybody do that too like
you just forget the end anyways so the
end is i wanted to say that the first
time i ever came to berkeley was about
15 years ago and my daughter said we
were ruining her life we came here on
sabbatical and um
i was firmly working in lower bounds and
circuit complexity and proof complexity
didn't know much about anything else and
i got introduced to
different
the definition of differential privacy
from
microsoft cynthia dwork and then
led to doing research in it and then
when i was very very lucky and then
about five years later the simon's
institute was born and i think i'd
probably speak for everybody it was just
an amazing game changer um both i think
for science but also for for me
personally it was just so wonderful to
come to so many different of these you
know programs and get to interact with
all sorts of people and learn about
really cool ideas
um
and the one on lower bounds which shafi
mentioned
she introduced me to the idea of
pseudo-determinism and i latched on to
that too is another just beautiful
definition
and then that led to
this notion of reproducibility so kind
of a
using that idea of pseudo-determinism in
the context of learning so that's what
i'm going to talk about today um and i
thought about going backwards in the
spirit of steve cook who would always um
sleep through the whole talk and then
somehow wake up at the very end and
get to the open problems but i think i
won't be able to carry that off so i'm
going to actually go from the beginning
but anyways i hope i get to this last
slide
so i want to start with
pseudo-deterministic algorithms
so let's say
so it's a really interesting concept
just for problems that are search
problems so by search problem i mean
there's an input of length n and there's
could be more than one solution
and we're going to consider search
problems that are easy for randomized
algorithms so some examples of important
ones are explicit construction problems
like given
n in binary
like given you know
n
one to the n you want to output a graph
on n vertices that's an expanded graph
another example number three very
similar to some extent is again given
and in in unary um you want to output a
function uh a truth table of length n so
it's a function on log log n bits that's
hard that can't be computed by small
circuits
another example is is finding a prime
given a number and in binary now output
some prime that's bigger than that
number
and these are examples of problems um
expanders for example in find hard
where you can just guess such a such a
you can just pick a random graph or you
can pick a random truth table of a
function and it's with extremely high
probability going to have the property
but the question is can you actually
pinpoint a specific one
in another example
uh is this is might look a little bit
different but um you you could start
with um an unsatisfiable
say three cnf formula and let's say it's
highly unsatisfiable so it's a random
one and let's say that by highly
unsatisfiable i mean that there's no
assignment that satisfies more than like
you know a constant fraction of all the
clauses and given an input alpha which
is an assignment to the variables you
want to output a violated clause and
here i'm thinking of a decision tree
model where you're allowed to query the
values of a variable and you want to
know how many variables you have to
query before you can find a violated
clause you can pick a clause at random
and check the variables in it and with
high probability if you pick a few
clauses at random you'll find one
because we were promised that you know
it's highly unsatisfiable but again the
question is how hard is it to locate a
particular one it's easy for randomized
decision trees
by the argument that we just gave it's
hard for deterministic and the notion of
pseudo-determinism is about whether you
can
output you know solve any of these
problems by outputting the same solution
but somehow using randomness to do that
does it make sense
so for these problems the um
these are all
the the random algorithm exploits the
fact that there's many good solutions so
you can just pick one at random but we
want to ask or uh this question was
asked by um get i think the first paper
and i forgot to write the reference
what's the first paper
that's what i thought so gotcha
goldbusters the first paper on this and
the question was what if the randomized
argument was required to output the same
solution almost all the time
so this gives the definition that an
algorithm is row pseudo-deterministic
for some search problem if for every
input x there's a fixed
y such that y is a good solution for the
input x and moreover the probability
over the randomness of the algorithm
that you output that good y is is high
it's at most it's at least one minus rho
okay
and the question is you know is it
easier to solve search problems
pseudo-deterministically rather than
deterministically in other words can we
sometimes it's very hard we think it's
very hard to come up with explicit
constructions of things even though lots
of them exist but can we somehow use
randomness to find one that's close to
you know that's close we think of
pseudo-deterministic as close to
deterministic because you're pinpointing
a particular solution but maybe with the
help of randomness
okay so just quickly um
turns out find expander is in p we now
have explicit constructions of that
maybe that's an important call
um
and find prime uh
it's
um
there's there was some progress on this
there's a now a sub-exponential
pseudo-deterministic
time algorithm so an algorithm that does
find a prime and it finds it in time i'm
lying a little bit but it finds a prime
under certain conditions
faster than the best known deterministic
algorithms
and find hard
this is still still open
um and the last example which is not
about polytime algorithms but about
the query model decision trees um here
um
we we proved about a year ago this was
the shafi russell
and rahul we showed that
pseudo-deterministic decision trees
require
um square root of n depth so in other
words it's hard
and interestingly the proof of this it's
easy to get the bound of like n to the
sixth or into the fourth
uh but it seems
we had to go through proof complexity to
get this lower bound and it's still open
to get the optimal uh omega well we
think the answer is omega n
lower bound although this is tight for
quantum decision trees so it's a open
question and also
like would like to find a a simple proof
or like a straightforward proof and you
can if you want to if you don't want to
think of this problem you can think of
the promise problem of you're given a
string in your promised that it has at
least n over two ones and you want to
output a one and you're allowed to query
the variables so the best we have for a
lower bound of square root of n here
it's the simplest problem and yeah i'd
like to know
i'd like to understand whether the true
answer is is omega then
um
yeah so why do we care maybe i should
have said that in the first place um so
i think i said this before so we i think
of pseudo-deterministic is almost the
same as deterministic um and so it still
it kind of pinpoints something explicit
for you but if since a relaxed notion
maybe we can speed up uh you know or
come up with constructions where we
couldn't deterministically and the
second reason to care which was i think
in the original paper and i didn't
really understand it until russell
helped me out
quite a bit
was they were motivated by the idea of
uh reproducibility or the replicability
crisis in science where you know
you can think about it as applying to
scientific experiments or machine
learning algorithms where you have a
bunch of data and you output some
hypothesis or you output some learning
algorithm and somebody else wants to
replicate it and if the you know the
algorithm or the the process involves a
lot of randomness and replication one
way to define it is that somebody else
can come and you know get the same
result the exact same result and so
pseudo-determinism was inspired by that
idea of trying to you know do something
that's replicable
um so i'm going to talk now about this
notion of reproducibility in the context
of learning
so and again it's a modification of the
definition of pseudo-determinism
for
for reproducible learning algorithms
yeah i think i'll skip this
so
the basic punch line here is that
there's this i don't know too much about
this but this reproducibility crisis
which has been along around for a long
time which you know
you've probably read lots of articles
about
published findings
uh that can't be reproduced and
sometimes they're false and sometimes
they're not and sometimes it's not known
whether they're false or not and the
reason you know one of the reasons i
don't know how to go backwards one of
the reasons is that you know when you do
an experiment and what you're supposed
to do is
ask your question collect all your data
you know check to see if your hypot make
your hypothesis collect your data check
to see if your hypothesis you know is
statistically significant uh if it is or
it isn't
drop the data ask a new question collect
new new data and so on and so forth of
course people don't do this because data
is very hard to to generate so people
tend to make you know adapt use the same
data on the second round of of
the experiment third round and so on in
machine learning the same thing happens
we reuse the data to you know to
fine-tune parameters
and that can lead to you know results
that don't generalize
so the new note this new notion of of
reproducible
learning uh is a way to sort of force a
learning algorithm to
collect data but produce the exact same
uh hypothesis with high probability and
i'll tell you just tell you give you a
flavor of it and just to tell you that
when i started this area when i started
working on this
russell and his students had already had
had this definition and i thought surely
there was it's a great definition but i
thought surely there's nothing that one
can do in this model and i was dead
wrong
so i'll tell you about some you know
bunch of algorithms that you things that
you can do reproducible reproducibly any
statistical query or statistical
learning um
heavy hitters approximate medium
learning finite concept classes and and
so on and most recently it turns out
that there's a very strong connection to
differential privacy that i'll hopefully
have time to describe at the end
okay
how much time
okay so let me just define it for you so
let d be a distribution over some
universe x and then out and think of a
as a learning algorithm but it doesn't
have to be
so if you think of it as a learning
algorithm a takes samples s from this
underlying distribution d so m think of
it as m labeled samples of some you know
concept and it also has random bits r
which you can think of as like a way to
set the hyper parameters or who knows
what
and
we'll think of the algorithm as you know
a learning algorithm so it out should
output a hypothesis
that um you know with high probability
uh uh
generalizes two samples from the
underlying distribution d
and so normally you don't put any
requirement reproducibility requirement
on the algorithm but we want to say a
learning algorithm is row reproducible
if for every distribution d over x
and for the probability where you fix
the random string r and then the
probability where you take two different
samples s1 and s2 that the algorithm
produces exactly the same hypothesis is
at least one minus rho
so you can think of this as for most r
the algorithm a outputs the same
hypothesis hypothesis for all
for almost all samples that you give it
okay
so to me that seemed like really strong
how would you ever expect learning
algorithms to do that
um
yeah so i'll show you that the yeah i'll
show you some examples of
this i want to just mention some related
notions
um
yeah so so the normal definition of
pseudo-determinism
uh it was was not designed for learning
so the normal definition you have the
input x and you have the random string r
and
you know there's no samples so you're
pseudo-deterministic
like we said before for every x there's
a particular y it's almost always output
so the difference between these two is
now we have samples and there's a notion
called global stability that
that came up in in some on a work
relating um different
approximate differentially private
learning to
to little stone dimension in that work
they defined a notion of global
stability
which is similar except that the
algorithm is deterministic so global
stability takes samples
and it out it's supposed to output a
hypothesis
h
the same hypothesis h over all the
samples so the difference between global
stability and our notion of
reproducibility is we have this extra
randomness and it turns out that that's
really is what is giving us the power
so to do things globally in a globally
stable way typically uh this delta is
extremely small it's like you know one
over a polynomial
and
uh and then the third definition called
pseudoglobal stability this was defined
around the same time as as our paper but
we didn't know about this work and this
is basically the same as our definition
so it's you modify global stability by
adding this extra random bits
and then again you require that for
almost all random bits for any two cent
you know
for for most of the sample sets that you
would pick it gives you exactly the same
hypothesis
okay so why is this nice
so first of all it's an algorithmic
property it's a probability of the
algorithm and it's efficiently testable
so unlike lots of other properties like
differential private you know testing if
something's differentially private is
is is not trivial at all whereas this is
easier to test
you just can you can just run it and
check to see that all results but almost
always outputs the same hypothesis it's
distribution independent so it's a
guarantee no matter what distribution
the algorithm is given
and we'll see again that from what i
said before that this private randomness
r is we're going to really leverage that
um to help us and uh
works no matter what the output of a is
and we can amplify the error row or we
could reduce the error row amplify the
success probability
and reproducible algorithms learning
items also generalize so these are some
nice properties that it has
so i'll just give you a flavor of some
of the
some of the ideas behind it
okay so the first thing is i just want
to do a statistical query a simulate a
statistical query so d is a distribution
over domain x and f is some function
from elements in the universe to numbers
so for example f of x could be the
height of a person
and
what we want to do given a bunch of
samples from this distribution is we
want to reproducibly compute the
expected value of this function okay so
the expected height of people in the
population
and again reproducibly means we take a
bunch of samples we're allowed to use
extra randomness but we want to almost
all the time output exactly the same
answer okay
so what would you do non-reproducibly
you just pick m samples and you output
the empirical average and you know this
is not hard to do you don't need that
many samples
uh
but it's it's not gonna it's always
gonna give you a slightly different
answer okay
so one idea is that you could divide the
interval and you know the expected
values between zero and one so you could
divide the interval into small uh
small interval divide the whole thing
into intervals of
size alpha or alpha is pretty small and
then
you can do the same thing you did before
take a bunch of samples compute the
empirical average but then round to
the midpoint of the interval that you
lie in
okay and so for example in this picture
the red would be the true average and
the empirical average since we picked
enough samples with very high
probability it'll be very close to
to the red to the true answer and then
we'll make sure we pick enough samples
so that uh
bouncing to the nearest
cutoff point uh the nearest black line
plus the air the the air between the red
and the blue that that'll all you know
that will be that that'll all be at most
tau which was which is the confidence
that we want okay
so that looks good except that there's
going to be some so that's going to work
for most cases but there is going to be
this worst case scenario where the
intervals that we picked it might happen
to be that the true answer the red one
is super close to one of those cutoff
points and if that happens then the
empirical one can be on either side so
in that case sometimes you'll go left
and sometimes you'll go right and so you
won't you know you won't output the same
thing with probability greater than a
half so this is where the use of the
randomness comes in so we'll just modify
that l that algorithm by instead of
fixing these these you know intervals to
start at zero we'll pick a random offset
alpha offset and then we'll just you
know and that's gonna be how we're gonna
avoid this worst case scenario you pick
the random offset do the same thing we
did before and now with high probability
you know you're not gonna
you're not gonna you know be the the
true value is not gonna be right really
really close to one of those cutoff
points
and yeah
the the analysis is just turn off but
it's pretty easy to see that it doesn't
do much worse than the original one
okay and just two takeaways so now we're
mapping a large output space you know
which is all
any possible number and zero to one two
canonical representatives via some
randomized routing rounding and we'll
see that correlated sampling is actually
a tool we didn't realize it uh but now
we do i'll talk about that in a minute
but but that's a really useful tool in
this to make things reproducible and um
another thing you know what you did see
is that you so the use of randomness is
super important it allows us to convert
this worst case situation to average
case
so i won't tell you about heavy hitters
but
again it's not too complicated of an
algorithm
but it does again use
use randomness in an essential way
and so we give an algorithm for
reproducibly computing heavy hitters of
a distribution
and uh the sample complexity is just
depends on
rho that's the reproducibility parameter
and epsilon which is you know the error
and the interesting thing is independent
of the universe size so heavy hitters is
hard for statistical queries so it can
do some things that statistical query
algorithms can't i mean they can do them
much more efficiently in terms of sample
complexity
and then we use the heavy hitters
algorithm to um compute approximate
median
and
this this algorithm that we have is
similar in spirit
to
differ to differential private
approximate differentially private
algorithms for the same problem and it
has a very similar run uh sample
complexity
the log star of the size of the universe
is because of a recursive iterative
tree-like procedure
yeah so now i just want to quickly tell
you about learning finite concept
classes because it's pretty easy
so i want to show that if you have any
finite concept class that you can uh
even if in even in the agnostic setting
you can
you can reproducibly
pack learn
with this sample complexity
and it should look similar to the
typical sample complexity
of
of of learning a concept class that's
that's accepted has the row in there
and our proof um
is it is a little bit complex
well it's a little bit complex but uh a
proof
that uh is inspired by
that i'll give you a really
i'll give you an intuition behind
another proof that goes via correlated
sampling so correlated sampling you know
is a
really powerful technique that was used
in the parallel repetition theorem it's
used to prove direct sum terms and the
idea behind it is that there's like two
players and they have two different
distributions p and q
then think of p and q as quite similar
so like their total variational distance
is is
you know they're close to each other um
and what the players want to do they
don't get to talk to each other but they
want to sample from their distributions
and what they want is for any
they want to share randomness and what
you want is that for
the probability over the randomness that
they
output the same value should be
it should be proportional to
how close they are in variational
distance so the closer they are the
higher the probability should basically
be one minus the distance between the
distributions the probability that they
output the same thing
so to reproducibly learn what you can do
is um
so let so first of all you
pick a bunch of samples enough samples
so that for every function in your
concept class you compute how well that
function does on those samples okay so
you compute the empirical error and it
doesn't take too many samples to do this
it's log of the size of the concept
class and
now if you have two different sample
sets where you did this on s and s prime
you can think about the induced
distribution so p sub s is an induced
distribution
over all the functions that have error
at most epsilon so over with samples s
you know we we did this calculation of
the empirical error of all the functions
and we keep the ones where the error is
at most epsilon okay and that gives we
can then we can normalize that and that
gives us a distribution over the good
functions do the same thing for s prime
that gives us two distributions that are
close to one another
and then if we just apply correlated
sampling well
justify but anyways ideas that you apply
correlated sampling to pick an f
and with a high probability proportional
to how close they are it'll be the same
one
we also have an algorithm for
house-based learning i won't have time
to to tell you about it but the one
thing that's super interesting to me is
that the way that we turned
the learning algorithm into a
reproducible one in this case the
hypothesis class is an infinite class so
these tricks we've used so far with
finite classes won't work but there's
this really beautiful work
this foams paper
and they it gives it it gives a
technique for rounding um all the points
in r to the d to to z to the d with a
property that nearby points in l2 space
will be mapped to the same thing with
high probability and we were able to use
that in this in this algorithm to turn a
learning element into a reproducible one
and then quite recently
gkm paper the same paper i mentioned
before that introduced the same
definition of ours they used showed how
correlated sampling could be used to
show that if you don't pay too much
attention to the parameters which aren't
very good that approximate differential
privacy was already known that that is
uh
that in little stone dimension or are
related in terms of their sample
complexity and they're also related and
also equivalent roughly to um
reproducibly learning
so it was a real surprise to me that
basically they're almost the same as
approximate differential privacy is
almost the same if you ignore this
exponential difference in sample
complexity
they're almost so reproducible learning
is actually feasible at least
theoretically feasible i don't know
about the actual practice that sylvia
was talking about but
okay so i think i don't have time for my
open promise but i just want to
say one just mention one thing i think
it's really interesting that um
correlated sampling comes up in all of
these things it's uh and i would like to
understand better the inherent um
relationships between parallel
reputation direct sum sampling and uh
correlated sampling foams and
reproducibility i know that sounds like
a lot but i think there's a you know
there's a real core of
there's a lot of commonality there that
we're exploiting it'll be nice to really
understand it better
also we don't have any idea about
computational efficiency of reproducible
learning so it's another area um yeah i
think that's it and back to the
beginning
[Applause]
great talk uh any any questions yeah
there's a question there
thank you very much it was uh very
interesting so one thing that it didn't
catch is it a proper algorithm or
improper yeah it is proper
yeah we're just look we're taking every
single function in the concept class
and estimating its error and then we're
going to output one of those
thanks for a great talk tony uh good
question what do we know about the
dependence on p does it have to be uh
unreal uh or oh yeah right the
parameters so you mean for the
um you mean for the
for the uh for the whatever uh you can
the computation or the
uh
polynomial is usually like a row squared
in in the denominator typically but is
the do we know that it's necessary
um
i think we do know a rose type
one of the rows right
yeah russell has a question or an answer
uh of course you can ask the question
about reproducibility or replicability
we haven't decided on the name yet um
for a lot of different contexts but the
simplest context
is the
the statistical query
and for that we have a tight lower bound
that shows that you need a factor of one
in rho squared
thanks robbie
your definitions require generally exact
equality
if the algorithm outputs a real valued
especially real valued vector
then is there some general way to deal
with that i mean you had it you had
dealt with it by quantizing for the
median but more generally high
dimensional real value vector as an
output
then your condition your requirements
are fairly strong for equality great
yeah that's why i was so surprised so
even for this half split half space
learning with large margin
um
yeah we do we do meet the guarantee that
output's exactly the same
and it's continuous
so i think my privilege is a
what's approximate dp
oh so approximate normal dp you have one
parameter epsilon and you say that um
for nearby databases the you know
basically the difference between them
has to be like e to the epsilon but for
approximate you have two primes epsilon
delta it's like a probably it's like a
probably approximately correct so you
can ignore the tails with probably for
all but you know with probability at
most
one minus delta this condition is met
okay so the really rare events you can
forget about
thank you thank you very much for a
great talk and we have a break